this is a production of Cornell
University
well thank you so much Don thanks for
inviting me to come and do this talk
today I'm really excited to be back here
and to show everyone what I've been
doing for the past 10 years so first of
all I just like to start out with what a
city Forester does because it's
confusing to a lot of people so they
think like forestry they think like
timber production like what are you
doing exactly
so obviously Street trees is pretty much
the main thing that I work on
so we manage all the street fees and
part trees in the city of Ithaca I'm
also in charge of the parks so I'm sort
of in charge of the parks department in
general and so this does anyone know
which Park this is I'm not calling on
Jules
no not be here part Washington Park
exactly
so that's Washington Pro great there so
I'm in charge of all the little pocket
parks and Stewart Park Kass park and the
rec program is run by the youth Carroll
but all the other parks I'm in charge of
so Stewart Park is one that I'm in
charge of there and then also random
things like the carousel down at Stewart
Park I have to hire carousel operators
and manage them throughout the summer
also the natural areas I try to do as
much as I can in the natural areas so we
have Eska Falls we have six Mile Creek
Natural Area those are all areas I try
to keep an eye on the city cemetery is
another section that I'm in charge in so
I've in my ten years I've had to sign
off on three burials in the city
cemetery so that's pretty exciting as
well and then also I just work with
other departments within the city so
whenever we have this is a picture of me
on the common so I was part of the
Commons design committee and things like
that planning department water and sewer
whenever they're doing projects that
might impact trees I work with them so
the city forester is more than just
trees and I've recently started watching
the show Parks and Rec and I really feel
like that is taken from my life so the
first it's just a little bit of
background from the city of Ithaca so
you kind of know where we're at here so
the first inventory was done in the
1930s by the first city for Sir Charles
Baker and we have this down in our
office it's this old street maps book
and it has all handwritten locations
with the trees with
notations on what they've been you know
what kind of tree they are if they were
removed and things like that and we're
working right now with the Cornell's
digital library to try to digitize this
so we can make it available to people
and people can look at it we have our
tree inventory online so you can look at
the tree that's in frontier house around
the block for me to look up what it is
and so this could maybe be linked to
that so you could see if you have a
really old tree could be like oh yeah
there it is in that book as well
we have over 11,000 street trees in our
inventory so that's the street trees and
the park trees it does not include trees
in a natural area or wooded areas we
don't have any of those inventoried and
our trees are on a four year inspection
rotation so we have different management
areas and every management areas
assigned to a particular year and so
each tree is looked at once every four
years so we can use that information to
base our work on so we can use that to
prioritize what work we're going to do
we also use Resident Collins and
complaints and things like that and
requests to create work but we are able
to prioritize some of our own work which
i think is pretty unique most cities
don't do that and so they really run off
a complaint driven system rather than
kind of prioritizing what might be the
most important work to be done and if it
has a forester and we have a dedicated
tree crew so we have a tree crew with a
bucket truck and we do our own work and
we can contract out a little bit of work
but we do mostly all of our own work
which is really rare for a city our size
most municipalities even larger than us
if they do do tree work they contract it
all out so that's really helpful for us
we can be very reactive we can really
change what we're doing on a dime we
don't have these big contracts that we
set up and then have to run through a
year before we change our priorities and
what we're doing and if ICCA's been
focusing on planting trees for many many
years and every time we remove a tree we
try to replace it within a year if it
makes sense to put a tree back in that
spot and we're at almost a hundred
percent stocking levels so that means we
don't have a lot of open spots that just
need trees so really when I make my tree
orders I have to really anticipate how
much work we're going to get how many
trees we're going to take out before the
next planting cycle starts make sure I
don't end up with a whole bunch of trees
I don't have places for and if the guy
has been a tree city for more than 30
years so tree city is a
Datak is a designation that the New York
State Dec manages and it's a it's a
national thing but the Dec manages it
for each state and so there's certain
criteria you have to meet it become a
tree city and we've been a tree city for
over 30 years so the first thing I want
to talk about is diversity and the city
of Ithaca has a very diverse urban
forest and there's reasons for that so
just for an example the Dutch elm
disease was introduced in the United
States in 1928 and it's a fungal
inspection that's spread by bark beetles
and so the damage that you see on the
trees what the beetle does but it
infests the tree was a fungus that kills
the tree and this is a picture of East
Ave here on Cornell campus and so it was
used to be all lined with elm trees and
there's a little stone here
kind of near de hall and it kind of
looks like a gravestone and it says
Ostrander on it and Ostrander was a
local farmer who wanted to contribute
something to the university when it
first started and so he contributed a
whole bunch of elm trees from his
property and they planted them all along
the road and then Dutch elm disease came
through and killed them all so this used
to be a monument as like honoring this
person who donated something and now it
looks like a tombstone for all these
trees that are no longer there and so
keeping that in mind that is really why
we have focused so much on making sure
we have a diverse urban forest because
things like that do come and things like
that will continue coming into our
community and so we need to make sure
that we have a diverse palette of trees
out there so that we don't lose an
entire Street of trees like that so we
have two hundred and seventeen different
tree species planted in the parks and
streets and comprising of 66 different
generous so here is what we've got here
so Norway maple is our most plentiful
tree it was a very popular tree at one
time and we've been slowly working down
the last time we did this analysis was
in 2013 and we are up around 12% was
Norway maple and now we've got it down
to about 10% so we don't plant Norway
maple anymore and we take a lot of them
out and so their proportions are
changing and then for genus obviously
maple again is going to be our most
popular with the Norway maple then mix
and silver maple and sugar maple and
things like that
a second is oak though and that was
interesting I was looking at that this
morning and thinking like so crabapple
is our second most popular species and
oat you don't see Oaks show up till down
here but it's our second most popular
genus so I was like trying to reason
that through and it's because Quercus we
just have so many different kinds so
many different species of oak when you
lump them all together we have a lot of
oak trees but when you put them out by
species we don't have a ton of any one
of them so so so diversity is something
really it's not like a new development
but it's something that the city has
been thinking about for a long time and
so it's kind of a new idea for some
communities they haven't really put a
lot of thought into it but for Ithaca
it's something that we've been doing for
a long time to keep our forests healthy
so another thing we've been working on
is creating good conditions for the next
generation of urban trees and so one
thing that we worked on and got
completed in like 2016-2017 was to
really update our ordinance for site
plan review so projects have to come
before site plan review if it's a big
development project and you know they're
tearing down a building and putting up
an apartment building or things like
that and so our our stuff that we had in
there requirements for the landscaping
and tree scaping was not great it wasn't
really clear it was somewhat out-of-date
and didn't really have a lot of teeth to
it didn't have a lot of helpful
information for developers either to
point them in the right direction and so
we worked on trying to create something
that had clear guidance and and
standards and would really create
optimal conditions for trees so that
they could meet their design their
design goal you know so you know when
they show you this picture of this tree
that's 30 feet tall and for another
building what do we really need to do to
make sure that that tree achieves that
status at some point it concludes
private property yes because it's like
when the but when the building is being
developed so when the lot is being
developed and sometimes that bleeds over
into the streetscape as well so as part
of their project they might have to
plant some Street trees so it's a it's
it can be both things
so one thing we looked at that kind of
motivated us to do this was looking at
the tree canopy so this was done by our
GIS folks at the
city in 2013 and it broke up in to our
different management areas and what the
forest canopy was the tree canopy of the
different sections and so there's a
recent study out of the University of
Wisconsin that said that you know they
are looking at about 40% canopy coverage
is what you kind of need to achieve a
good temperature mediation in the summer
for heat and things like that
so so we're doing pretty good we've got
some 40 45239
35 and I think Southside and Northside
are kind of low but that's because the
the lines are drawn kind of funny I
think if you look at the actual
residential areas they're very similar
to like Fall Creek so they probably fall
around the 40% as well so we really
wanted to think about making sure we're
preserving that because the mature trees
are the ones that are giving you the
most benefit so we can have developers
plant out a bunch of little new trees
but they're not going to provide a bunch
of shade for quite a while and also just
looking at the urban environment so this
is a picture from about 1900 this is
Green Street so right here you'd be like
a diamonds restaurant like kind of right
there and it's like press play alley so
this is the same view so looking down
here this house is that house there and
that house that one right there so you
look at how different that is these are
all elm trees this first one in line is
a maple and then there's a horse
chestnut and then a bunch of elm trees
so these are all honey locust so they're
different trees now but you can look at
you know in in the lifetime of a tree
you can definitely have a sugar maple
that lives through that lifespan and so
to think about how that environment has
changed for that tree over that that
course so you look at the street it's
been widened it's been paved there's
probably all kinds of utilities they
shortened up the tree lot and I've
narrowed it up to widen the road so when
you think about all these challenges
that trees are facing we really want to
try to preserve what we what we have and
so we wanted to protect protect existing
trees that are planted on the street and
that are on private property identify
utility conflicts in advance so that we
can maybe shift where the utilities are
and preserve trees and require adequate
protection this is very
common what is in there and when people
presents when developers present their
plans they often stipulate something
like this to preserve trees and it's
just like kind of you know put up a
fence just around the base of the tree
and that prevents people from backing
into it but it doesn't protect the
majority of the tree we have to think
about the root system of the tree and
protecting that so our tree protection
plan we require a site inventory so you
have to tell us what kind of trees are
on the site and what kind of condition
they're in because we don't want to list
a tree to be preserved that's already in
bad health we're gonna try to preserve
ones that are already in good health to
identify the critical root zone so
that's the really the most important
part of the roots that absolutely needs
to be maintained and protected if we
want the tree to survive long term
identifying if trees need to be pruned
before construction so oftentimes it
will be a building face that it's going
to be up against a street tree that did
that wasn't there before and so to prune
that before construction starts and not
wait till you know the Masons are coming
to put the bricks on they put up their
scaffolding and they need that tree trim
tomorrow and then they you know the
construction guys just show up with
their sawzalls and just go at it to make
space like that's the type of thing we
want to try to avoid identify proper
protection measures so to make sure
we're protecting as much space around
the tree as we possibly can identify if
there's any post construction care so if
we need to say that they have to mulch
the trees and they have to water them
for the first year or two things like
that to kind of help the trees if
they're being stressed and then also I
how protection is going to be
communicated so a lot of these big jobs
there's multiple subcontractors that
come in and so every you know the
electricians come in and the Masons come
in and then the plumbers come in and to
make sure that everyone coming on to
that site understands why that fencing
is there and that it can't just be moved
because you want to park your truck in
the shade or because you have some
material being delivered and you need to
set it somewhere so to have
documentation on that fence to say this
is tree protection it cannot be moved
other things that we can ask for is
things like air speeding so if we really
want to preserve a tree but a utility
line has to be run to in the building
you can use high-powered air to blow the
soil out and protect a lot of the roots
and without severing them and then just
feed your line underneath so yes we
so so preserving trees mature trees is
one thing we want to do and then also
making sure that the new trees that are
being planted are being set up for
success to make sure that they have that
inter ground infrastructure so they can
realize your design intent so really
thinking about what are they building
underground to support trees so soil is
really important and I talk about soil
so much when I do my review of site
planned criteria I'm always talking
about dirt like they're probably like oh
the dirt lady's talking about soil again
so often in urban environments the soil
is poor quality it's poor structurally
so often it's very compacted so it
doesn't have those macro pores in it
that will hold moisture that will allow
for air exchange and things like that
that the tree roots need also
contaminants so there's a lot of
concrete which is affects the pH of soil
which can be a problem for some species
of tree and then also low soil volume so
that's the example here so if you just
don't have a lot of space for the tree
to grow it doesn't have the structural
support it needs and this picture is
from Queens New York where I used to
live and look at trees for the Asian
longhorn beetle and you know you'd get a
big windstorm and big trees would just
tip over because they just were growing
in little basically little you know
planting pots and they just fall over so
better care at planting so making sure
that the soil that the trees are being
planted in is high quality soil that
they can utilize so the scoop and dump
method is something we worked on with
Nina Basak she's been doing that here to
great success in a lot of the gardens
around here so the idea is that you put
a layer of compost on top of your
planting area and then you take a
backhoe and you just kind of gently paw
through the area to kind of get these
veins of compost to the soil so you're
not rototilling you're not totally
destroying the soil structure you're
just incorporating a little bit of
organic matter for the trees to access
and so like I said she's done it a bunch
of bunch up here on campus and we worked
with her to set up an experiment
downtown so along Route 13 where we have
a difficult time getting trees to
establish we picked about a dozen sites
and half of them got the scoop and don't
method and the other half didn't and
we're monitoring them they've all
survived the first year so we're gonna
have students out there monitoring
taking samples of the soil and things
like that and measuring the trees and
and seeing how much of a difference it's
making for the trees there the other
thing we're working on is mulch so like
I'm crazy about mulch as well so we have
March most mulch Madness where we mulch
things like crazy so it's really great
you know I don't know if we've got any
turf aficionados in here but trees do
not like turf so you know they don't
like to have that competition for
moisture or nutrients and things like
that so really what trees want is just a
huge mulch or on them so these trees
down our roots are chain you did the
same thing we gave them all a lot of
mulch to help them make it there so
thinking about all that we did have some
new standards in our and our ordinance
that we pass for site plan review so we
want to try to preserve soil so making
sure that their staging is thought of so
where are we gonna stage all the
equipment for this construction making
sure that we have a minimum of entrances
into the site so that people aren't just
driving all over the tree lawn and
compacting all the soil before new trees
are planted and making sure that the
sites are prepared adequately that we
have enough soil volume for trees and we
have some other things that we suggest
that people use or not requirements but
there suggestions that they can use one
thing with the urban environment is just
trying to pack a lot of stuff in there
so you have your street you want to have
off street parking you want to have a
bike trail you want to have a sidewalk
and a tree lawn and that's a lot of
space to fit in the right-of-way there
and people want to build right up to
their property lines as well so they can
maximize the square footage of the lot
as well so trying to make areas that can
overlap is helpful so people have seen
tree grapes before they're these big
metal grapes that go over trees but
they're kind of difficult to deal with I
don't really like them that much as a
tree grows you kind of have to cut away
the metal in some way to make sure
there's enough room through the tree if
there's some surface roots or things
like that the grates can get uneven and
then become tripping hazards not really
a good way to fix that so this is a
product that we've been a kind of
experimenting with called flexi pave and
there's other products out there that
are the same thing but they're it's
ground-up tires and a little bit of
gravel and then they mix it with an
epoxy and spread it on there
it just water runs right through it but
it is a surface that passes a eighty
eight standards so American with
Disabilities Act to make sure it's a
level enough surface that people with
different walking abilities can can use
that surface safely and so that's
helpful one thing I've been thinking of
is the dark color of it though and I'm
wondering if we should be recommending a
lighter color of it because it does seem
to get pretty hot especially with these
young trees that aren't casting a lot of
shade on it yet and I'm wondering how
that affects the soil temperature so
that would be an interesting thing to
look at the difference of survivorship
with trees that have light-colored flexi
pay versus darker colored flexi be
another thing we try to encourage is
structural soil which is another thing
that Nina and her graduate students
worked on here at Cornell and so
structural soil is basically like number
dirty number two stones so it's number
two stone all the fines are taken out of
it so all the pieces are irregularly
shaped but they're the same dimensions
basically and you can pack them together
and get the compaction you need to put
pavement and things like that on top of
it but there's enough gaps in between it
because the pieces are so irregular and
they don't fit together real tight like
a puzzle that the tree roots can
actually move through it and it doesn't
work for every tree species but there's
a lot of tree species that can access
that so here's an example of something
we put in our ordinance for developers
to look at and reference and it this is
one of Nina's students created this for
us and so you don't have to use
structural soil just you know an example
like this where you want to pave over it
you can also use it in an example like
this where you're just putting it under
the flags of the flags of sidewalk right
adjacent to the tree so the tree can
move through that structural soil and
then access whoopsies and then access
the lawn on the other side of the
sidewalk and so if you don't really have
a huge soil volume in the actual tree
long trees can still get past that
barrier of the compacted soil of the
sidewalk and access the soil on the
other side so here's another thing that
is in our ordinance that I was pretty
excited about so here is wagons and
Eggman's parking lot and tops in that
parking lot and these other parking lots
so this is 2002 and this is 2013 and
those parking lots look exactly the same
so those trees that are growing their
head a decade to get bigger and there's
like no measurable difference you can't
see that they've gotten any bigger
so parking lot design is something that
really needed a lot of help and so it's
there's again the same situation as on
the street low soil volume poor soil
quality oftentimes it's just kind of
whatever soil they have leftover from
construction and they pile it up and put
a curb around it stick a tree and it put
some mulch on top and call it good and
it doesn't usually turn out well species
selection was also not very great in a
lot of situations so for a parking lot
you want to pick a species that is very
drought tolerant and heat tolerant and
that's not what we were seeing a lot of
the parking lots around and there was
also no establishment care so there is
nobody out there watering the tree for
the first year or two to help it get
established so it's pretty much good
luck to your tree and most times they
don't make it and they die and you stick
another tree in and it dies and put
another tree and that's just perpetual
but those trees are never growing to the
point where they're actually producing
shade for that parking lot so we put in
our ordinance recommendations to make a
better parking lot
so we require adequate soil volume so
you need an actual legitimate soil
you couldn't just scrape up whatever you
had leftover construction you need to
actually have legitimate soil and in the
right quantities to support the type of
tree that you're suggesting so if you're
just putting crabapples that's less soil
and if you're going to try to grow a
honey locust or something like that we
also require a really high planting area
of 25% so that's a quarter of your
parking lot needs to be needs to be
planting area and nobody wants that
because the parking lot is there for
people to park in so in order to give up
some of that percentage you can upgrade
some other things to minimize that
planting area so if you have stormwater
Swale so you have these little curb cuts
on you and you slope the and grade the
parking lot in a way that the soil can
run into those swales it can water the
trees one thing you have to think about
is making sure you have an under drain
because these situations can kind of be
like boom or bust like totally bone-dry
and then when it rains
the water from the parking lot floods in
there and if there's no outlet or
overflow they just become bathtubs and
then the trees drown so you have to
think about that and then we also say
have suggestions for structural soil too
so this is an example of here's your
planting area in actual organic soil and
then beyond that you can have structural
soil that you can use porous pavement
over and then you can use that for
parking spots so you so a planting area
that used to be this big you can fit two
more cards there if you if you put in
this other infrastructure and this is
showing different scenarios so if you
have two small trees how far apart do
they have to be if you have a larger
tree or very large tree how much soil
volume do you have to provide for those
trees so I think it would be much nicer
to show up to a parking lot that looks
like this and to come out to your car
when you're done shopping and not have a
card that's like 120 degrees inside but
it's a matter of motivating developers
to put in that infrastructure to do that
and it's interesting because since we
had this in effect we've only had one
parking lot be designed and that's the
green star parking lot where they're
moving there by purity ice cream and so
they have their water from the parking
lot is flowing into the tree area and
they have a drain for it and so we'll
see how those trees do over time it'll
be a nice experiment to see if those you
know in the next 10 years those trees
really grow and are providing shade to
that parking lot and then we can go back
and look at you know the parking lots
down on the south side and still the
same trees the same size and not
providing any shade another thing I've
really put a lot of effort into is
public engagement and so we do a lot
with public engagement in relation to
the street trees one thing I'll start
with this one I guess so we have signs
that we put up on the trees let's say
this tree is scheduled to be removed
city of Ithaca and a phone number so
that people can call and ask like why is
this tree going to be removed whatever
and one day we found this on a tree
someone had taken off that sign and put
the sign on and you know it doesn't make
you mad at all like I love it because it
shows that people in this community are
they care about trees they're engaged
you know and so I think it's great so I
put this up my
and I still have it there and so you
know it's great to have that point of
contact with people that if they're
concerned about why did you make a
decision to take this tree down or not
then I can have a conversation with them
and say okay well I know it's a really
big old tree it's a sugar it's a silver
maple it's hollow it's dropping limbs
it's not safe you know and people are
you know they come to terms with it they
understand that like okay it's a safety
thing it's sad that that tree has to go
but it has to go and they always feel
better to know that we're gonna plant
another tree in its place and and all
that another thing is with tree
establishment so for years we'd been
putting these green watering bags on
trees and I think at first people just
didn't even know what they were like
what is this there for and then we
started putting flyers in people's doors
when they got a new tree in front of
their house that said you know please
water the tree please take care of it
give us a call if you have any problems
here's what kind of tree it is and then
I would still get calls from people
being like I tried to water it but I
don't understand I'm putting water in it
it's flowing through I don't understand
so then we made this little
informational card that we just laminate
and then stick on the bags and it shows
you exactly how to fill it up with a
picture and what it's doing and how it
works and what my phone number is if you
still have questions and I found it to
be very effective most people want to
water their tree and they just like
don't know how to do it and so this has
really helped and so I'll drive around
and I'll see water bags full out there
after we plant trees for the first
summer each tree gets this that just got
planted and so it's really reduced the
amount that we have to send out the
water truck to go in water tree so look
we're trying to do something great for
the environment we're trying to plant
trees and then we have to send out this
big diesel guzzling truck with water to
fill the trees like it just didn't
really make sense in my mind so to try
to limit that as much as we can and so
the last few years we've really limited
the watering that we have to do we wait
until there's like a real stretch with
no rain and then I prioritize the trees
that are in commercial districts or just
in neighborhoods where I feel like
they're not really getting watered and
so it really limits the amount of
resources we have to put into it and
it's not it's not very hard for people
to water to water their trees and then
people also get a notice after the trees
removed they get
notice in their door when we go to grind
the stump so that they can call me and
have any kind of input on the new tree
that they get so they can either select
from the species that I'm going to order
or if there's something they really have
their heart set on and it seems like it
would be a good match for that spot and
it's available I'll order it for them so
that they have that investment into the
tree and so they care about it they'll
remember to water it they'll remember to
call me if they think there's something
wrong with it
so that just in that little bit more of
effort really gets people more engaged
and the tree that's in front of their
house we've also been working on doing
tree tours and so we did a few tree
tours we partnered with bike walk
Tompkins and we did some bicycling tree
tours of a couple neighborhoods we had a
tree tour already of Stewart Park we did
one for the city cemetery as well so we
have one for Fall Creek and Southside
neighborhood and so you can go on to the
city website and just search for tree
tour and you can find this and you can
call it up on your phone and it you know
you click one of the tours and it zooms
in and it shows you like the path to
walk and you get to each tree and it has
a little paragraph about what's special
about that tree so you can use this to
get to know the trees in your
neighborhood the thing we're working on
currently is a residential tree or
Donets and so we taking a look at the
canopy coverage we realize that most of
the really great canopy coverage is
internal to the block so it's really not
so much the street trees that are doing
it so the trees inside the blocks and so
there are communities that do require
permits or have restrictions on trees
that you can remove from your own
property and so we've been exploring
that and and I've interviewed a couple
other communities that have ordinances
like that
and we're trying to figure out how we
can best fit that into the city of
Ithaca and so there's definitely
preservation was trying to tell people
how they can manage their own property
but I think it's important if really
what we want to do is is prove as a
protect that tree canopy it's something
we really have to think about doing and
it does seem that in some communities
it's not so much that they're really
trying to prevent a rule of trees but
they just want that one more point of
contact with someone that could come out
and say well what's your goal for
removing this tree oh it has some dead
limbs well you could really actually
prune it you don't need to remove it or
you know you don't like raking the
leaves well maybe we could get a
neighbor
help you out we don't really have to
remove the tree right now so just having
it one more point of contact maybe
prevent some of that is kind of what
we're looking at right now so we're
doing a lot in the city of Ithaca and
I'm pretty proud of the work that we do
we've you know we're working on
diversity of species all the time we
constantly trying to update our
ordinance we're working on possibly
doing a new ordinance trying to protect
the trees we have focusing on
underground infrastructure for trees and
you know really getting the public
engaged and caring about the trees in
the city so this is a kind of a
promotional pamphlet that the tree City
for New York State came out with and so
it has all kinds of statistics on it
there and if the co right here it has
the longest growth award so the tree
city USA has four four criteria you'd
have to meet to become a Tree City USA
so once you've met that you can pretty
much do it every year so Poughkeepsie
got in there at the ground level and
they have 40 years so we're only at 30
something we're never going to catch up
with them but if you go above and beyond
those four criteria you earn points
towards earning a growth award and
Ithaca has earned a growth award 21
years and that's the most of any city in
the state of New York so I'm pretty
proud about that too and so if there's
any questions I'm happy to answer
questions for the next few minutes can
further orders follow me things like
Israel is to concentrate right is that
happening with your tree yeah that's
exactly how the tree bags work so oh yes
so ken was asking about trickle
irrigation and doing a slow watering of
trees so you get a deeper water rather
than a surface watering that just kind
of runs off and doesn't doesn't put it
doesn't target a lot of the water at the
tree roots so that's exactly what the
tree bags do the watering bag so it's a
double wall structure and you fill fill
it up so that you have this kind of like
doughnut of water and then in the bottom
of the bag there's very little holes and
so the water literally just drips out so
you fill it up and it takes
maybe all day for the water to drip out
and so that allows the water to seep in
really deeply into the soil so if you
just go out there with a garden hose and
you stand there for 20 minutes you might
dump gallons of water on it but you're
watering a very shallow amount over a
wide area and what's best for the trees
is a very deep watering over a very
small area where's all the new roots are
and so that's exactly what the water bag
is doing so they're much more effective
than just pouring water on the tree well
we only water them like that for the
first year so it's really just tending
to those new roots that are just right
kind of trying to branch out and then we
take it out you can zip them together so
you have a bigger tree you can kind of
keep increasing that diameter you can
because there's just zip errs you can
just zip two together three together and
then fill them up all around the tree so
if you're transplanting larger trees or
you have a particularly drought
sensitive tree that you just want to
water through the summer it's a great
way to do that done jadynn responds to
both changing climate and new diseases
and insects in what ways are you
changing the species mix of trees you
select each year yeah so Don's question
was about species selection in the face
of changing climate and new insect
infestations and so that's all what
we're going for with our diversity so
we're always looking to make sure we
have a diverse number of species so that
when we get new diseases that we that we
have a diverse palette of trees out
there we're always looking for new
varieties that are coming out so we
usually like something will come out and
I'll notice it or Nena will notice it in
the trade and say we should grab a
couple of these and you plant some and
see if they work and if they do well we
order more and then for climate change
we do find that we can get away with
some pretty winter tender trees down in
downtown in Ithaca so we can plant we
have some trees that are like zone seven
trees some of those leather leaf
magnolias those evergreen magnolias that
we have downtown they've been there for
fifteen years now maybe and they're like
a zone seven you see those growing on
medians down in Florida so so we're
always kind
trying to push the envelope and see what
new species we can get to establish
sorry yes I wonder if you have any
thoughts about mulch and the Asian worth
were those earthworms seemed of
completely colonized in South Side yeah
another thing what if you use hardwood
mulch it seems to just encourage them to
go crazy yeah yeah so the question is
about the use of organic bark mulch or
ground-up mulch and Asian earthworms
which is a species that's come in here
and it's it's pretty bad especially for
forested areas they really can plow
through that organic layer on the soil
and just just decompose it far quicker
than is normal for this area and it
causes problems with erosion and things
like that
and so I have found that they do they
chew right through that stuff pretty
quickly so last year I had the parks
crew mulch big areas underneath some
trees where it was so shaded that we
didn't have much grass and I said you
know what let's just put big mulch mulch
islands out there we'll probably only
have to do it every other year and just
driving by some of those parks this year
like that mulch is almost totally gone
already and I think it must be the Asian
earthworms I find them pretty much
everywhere in Ithaca we've done we
planted a bunch of bulbs up in Bryant
Park up in Bell Sherman they're there
they're downtown in front of my office
so garden there I work on I think
they're pretty widespread through
probably most of the city you know dam
damaged young trees so because it seemed
like once they run out of mulch the
trees sometimes they go deeper in shock
I haven't noticed that we don't
replenish the mulch on street trees
typically so the trees get mulch when
they get planted and then after that
they're kind of on their own so either
grass grows up to them or some or the
homeowner puts in mulder's so the only
time we kind of remould is the in the
parks and I haven't I haven't really
found that to be an issue yet but
definitely something to consider because
they are very aggressive
plentiful so from the diversity question
of what you're selecting are there any
other sort of ecosystem services that
you're considering i mean you've talked
about the heating mm-hmm
feature but pollinators things like that
or any other considerations everything
yeah so the question is about
considerations when we're choosing new
species and diversity and are we just
focusing on purely diversity are we
looking for other attributes in the
trees and certainly we are so you know
we try to plant like I was saying Oaks
you know that's one species that
supports a whole whole plethora of
different insects it's one of the best
Genesis to to plant if you're want to
support diversity ecosystem and so we
have a lot of different kinds of oak
trees we try to we try to plant as much
native stuff as we can so the area along
the side of the street isn't necessarily
native habitat so we can't get native
trees to grow in all those places but
whenever we can do native trees we try
to do that and yeah like nesting
I mean squirrels right yeah yeah I
wouldn't say necessarily that we think
about that I do feel like unfortunately
a lot of our activities reduces nesting
opportunities because the trees that
we're usually pruning and removing our
trees that have cavities in them and so
we definitely don't have a you know a
blanket statement where if a tree has a
cavity in it we got to cut it down we
got to remove it I definitely like if I
notice there's a cavity I have the tree
crew check it out they'll investigate it
they'll see how it decayed it is and
kind of we make a determination whether
we can leave it or not I have left a
couple tall tree stumps as well there's
been some residents that are willing to
leave that in front of their house and
I'm willing to leave that in for another
house and we have these signs that say
this this is like habitat and it'll come
down eventually but you know let the
woodpeckers pick away at it and stuff
like that so if you take all the
branches off you really are reducing the
risk that it's gonna damage anything or
injure anyone so we do try to do that
but that is something
conscious of us and I feel like you know
we're really making a lot of cavity
masters homeless a lot of times with
with our Street cheese yep we have at
Stewart Park for sure we've definitely
put a bunch of nesting boxes I just put
up a chickadee nesting box and for my
office so I can see from my window and
I've thought about that to the
possibility of putting up you know
bigger nesting boxes if we do have to
take away a big tree you know is there
another big tree across the street that
is you know I'm thinking of one
situation where we have a silver maple
that I know is not in good situation but
the one across the street is a big
sycamore that doesn't have any holes in
it so if we put a nest box in that tree
the thing the problem kind of my
stumbling block with that is then how do
we maintain it so how do we go back and
make sure we're cleaning out the nest
box how do we make sure that that isn't
going to become a hazard and rot and
then fall off the tree and so it's a
time commitment if we start putting that
stuff out there we have also worked with
nice egg so so the nice egg forrester is
really into birds his wife works at
Cornell lab ornithology and so I've
worked with him we've put up a bunch of
Osprey nesting posts down at Stuart Park
we have an owl nesting cone up in Stuart
Park as well so we try where we have
opportunities like that to do things
like that we have yes so that's
something I didn't put in here but we
have yeah so we over the past I don't
know five or six years and been trying
to pick away at her ash and then we
found it infestation two years ago and
we treated some of the ash trees and
we're continuing to try to take some of
them down so we are trying to do a slow
swap over and preserving a lot of them
so hopefully when we get that to that
part in the cycle where there's like all
the trees are just dying all at once
will we'll have more of a handle on it
and a lot of communities have found
themselves anything else
have you found any challenges with the
permaculture part and some of the fruit
trees that they're any particular just
sure
yeah so the question was about down in
conley park which is behind the Science
Center
it's kind of also been named
permaculture parks there was a
Cooperative Extension group that wanted
to make that more of a permaculture
garden and have fruits and things like
that that people could just walk through
and gather if they wanted to I haven't
had any issues with that um in terms of
like people really complaining about it
or having any problems like that it is a
maintenance is always an issue and so we
don't at the city we don't really have
staffs I can maintain something like
that and so we rely on Cooperative
Extension there's been a lot of
volunteers from green star they've come
over and helped as well so that's that's
the main issue with that I do get
questions from people sometimes when
we're planting a new tree as a street
tree and they want our persimmon or they
want a walnut or they want something
like that and I really try to steer them
in a different direction I I definitely
appreciate the thought process behind
permaculture and the intention and
everything it's just very difficult
especially in Ithaca where we have a
transient community where the person
who's like promises they're gonna take
care of that mulberry moves away in
three years and then the next person
that moves in it's like there are these
mulberries all over my car you know so I
try to I try to steer people in other
directions I think parts are maybe good
opportunities for that but just along
the street there's a lot of
complications there unfortunately one
last question from Tom dear Victoria
wall stone walling up University Avenue
cemetery centers yes recently yeah
question a lot of the two stones within
and great sites within the cemetery have
trees growing over them they're
obviously very destructive of the former
Cemetery units yeah sure so Tom's
question it was about the city cemetery
so our city cemetery is pretty old like
I think the first burial and there was
like in 1790 or something ridiculous
like that so it's expanded over time but
there are some very very old stones in
that cemetery and if you come up the
lower side
cemetary along University of there's
like old just laid stone retaining wall
there and I did have the true crew go
through and remove a bunch of trees
there this winter almost all the trees
they removed from there were Atlantis so
Tree of Heaven which is a non-native
species and a lot of them were in really
bad condition and so they were they're a
very brittle tree as well and we were
just having a lot of Collins where
branches were falling or chunks of the
tree were falling in the road there and
with the curve it just wasn't a safe
situation so I'd wanted them to do it
for a couple years and this winter I
finally got them in there to do that so
that's that's primarily what we removed
from that wall and then yeah I think the
cemetery definitely went through a
period where it wasn't really that
tightly maintained and I think a lot of
meaty trees got in there there's a lot
of mulberry and Norway maple and things
like that that just kind of seated
themselves in and they might have been
next to a stone and didn't get mowed
around and then they grew and now
they're chipping the stone over so we do
have a lot of that and I've been trying
to do a little bit better maintenance
there at the cemetery and we do have a
group now the Friends of the city
cemetery that's putting a lot of effort
into you know writing up some of the
stones and raising some money additional
money for the cemetery the difficult
thing about the city cemetery is the way
that New York State law is if you're a
private cemetery there's different
funding opportunities so if it's a
church held cemetery or something like
that or a private family cemetery that's
historic there's different funding
opportunities and grants you can get but
if it's a municipal cemetery you're not
allowed to access those funds you're not
allowed to apply for those funds I think
the thought process is well it's a
municipality so you can just keep
digging into the taxpayers pockets and
increase taxes if you need to fix the
cemetery you're not going to go bankrupt
you know but it doesn't work that way
like you know I have gotten some money
for the cemetery
we had a seventy-five thousand dollar
capital grant from the city the city's
funding to repair some of the vaults
that are on that hillside and then
Cornell donated seventy-five thousand
dollars to match what the city was
putting in so we're able to fix a bunch
of those faults but I think the cemetery
is a really missed opportunity I think
we really need to treat it more like a
park because it is 17 acres of green
space right in downtown and so that's
why we've created the tree tour there to
try to get more people in there to walk
through it and really use it as a part
and use it as a green space and use it
as a trail and possibly if we can
designate it as not just a cemetery but
a city park that might open us up to
some other funding opportunities some
part funding opportunities but it's
really challenging it's hard to do tree
work there it's hard to get equipment in
there a lot of that work I have to
contract out which becomes expensive so
it's something I'm I'm pretty passionate
about it
I think it's a really miss space and I
just found out we're gonna have a bird
the bird the Cornell bird Club there's a
cave the bird Club is going to do a
birding session there in the spring to
bring people out and to wander through
there and see what kind of Warblers and
whatnot we can find there thank you for
coming on such a beautiful day you
could've been outside or you came here
to live this has been a production of
Cornell University on the web at Cornell
edu